Ich bin freundlich…
so da bin ich heute machen wir mal wieder was und zwar wir versuchen ich glaube das
wird nicht so lange dauern weil entweder geht das oder es ist wahrscheinlich ein ding der
unmöglichkeit mal gucken mal gucken wir versuchen eine neue tv header in version ja wir versuchen
uns eine eigene tv eine neuere tv header in version zu kompilieren ich habe eine anleitung
gefunden das müsste von der theorie her gar nicht so kompliziert sein weil das problem ist
zeige euch ich zeige es ich zeige es euch auch gleich wenn das stream richtig richtig angelaufen
ist ja ich warte noch kurz ja bis dass die leute auch die chance haben hier erstmal anzumachen und
so die anderen leute ich bin jetzt zwei minuten zwei minuten 20 und andere haben ein prerun intro
dings vorm stream von zehn minuten also bisschen bisschen zeit den leuten lassen dass man ihr
anrücken kann muss man also wie gesagt an sich funktioniert der receiver tatsächlich erstaunlich
gut also der ist wirklich top da kannst du gar nichts sagen das einzige ist dass die eingebaute
die eingebauten sachen halt zacken also das das interface und und dies eingebaute streaming mit
dem kodi plugin das ist halt ziemlicher müll aber von der hardware und jetzt mit tv header ist das
richtig nice das teil leider oder was heißt leider eigentlich ist ja ok ich bräuchte gar nicht
unbedingt eine neue tv header in version die tv header in version die ich habe die hat einen
kleinen bug beim scheduling wenn du aufnahmen hast wenn sich eine auch keine ahnung ob ich
noch richtig aus zusammen kriege wenn du eine serienaufnahme hast und nimmst direkt davor oder
danach eine manuelle aufnahme auf dann stimmt irgendwie die vorlaufzeit nicht mehr richtig
irgendwie so komischer bug und der ist mittlerweile auch gefixt meine tv header in version ist halt
zwei jahre alt ungefähr was das meine ist nicht als hätte ich was damit zu tun also die die man da
installieren kann die ist zwei jahre alt und das müsste mittlerweile gefixt sein und ehrlich
gesagt ich brauche das nicht das kommt nicht so oft vor also eigentlich kommt so gut wie nie
vor aber ich habe das mal anders genommen mal zu gucken ob man den kram nicht selber kompilieren
kann in die slots sonst gehe ich nie ach so wo wir gerade bei slots denn gucken wir uns mal
die real life slots an zwar was machen meine stonks die konnte ich was mal kurz gucken was
machen meine stonks heute heute stonks heute plus 130 euro stonks ja geht wieder hoch ich
sehe es und wisst ihr wisst ihr was wisst ihr was richtig was richtig stonks ist amazon hätte
ich mal mehr gekauft ja hätte ich mal mehr von aber nachher ist man immer schlauer hätte ich
mal mehr gekauft von amazon wir sind jetzt fast 300 euro gestiegen
ja gut ok also wo fangen wir denn jetzt an ich zeige euch mal was ich werde auch keinen
stonks stream machen weil ich habe davon ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung das einzige was ich kann ist
und ob sich das lohnt wird sich in den nächsten paar jahren zeigen ist world etf kaufen und liegen
lassen und das einzige was ich zusätzlich gemacht habe ist ich habe mir eine amazon
aktie gekauft als sie bei ziemlich genau 2000 euro war was macht tv tv tv hat end heißt das
das ist sowas ja ja sowas ähnliches ja ich zeige es ich zeige es euch also ich habe das gekauft
als das so gefallen ist vor zwei wochen oder so ungefähr zwei wochen da ist amazon richtig
krass runtergegangen und habe ich mir gedacht alle ich wollte immer mal eine amazon aktie haben da
habe ich für 2000 euro amazon aktie gekauft so ungefähr 2000 euro und die habe ich jetzt
halt mal gucken gucken vielleicht ich meine wenn das wieder so hoch geht wie am anfang des jahres
dann sind das 1000 euro plus da bin ich ja zufrieden mit hätte ich mir mehr kaufen sollen aber was
willst du machen ja man baut wie eine kryptowährung im stream kryptowährung zu bauen an sich ist
nicht sonderlich schwierig gibt es auf github jede jede menge sachen mit block chain ai und
gedöns bei ai braucht man nicht für egal aber das ist reichlich unsinnig kommt drauf an es
kann ja auch richtig krass auf der anderen seite wer hat mal jemand gesagt letztens auf twitter das
fand ich eine fife hetter sache du verlierst nur geld erst wenn du verkauern wir haben es
gehabt verlierst nur kohle er nicht du verlierst die kohle ja nur wenn du es verkaufst deswegen
hodeln wahrscheinlich weil krypto sachen auch so viel wie gesagt ich habe keinen plan von
solchen geschichten deswegen werde ich euch auch nicht empfehlen irgendwas zu machen weil ich habe
dieses jahr immer noch minus aber ganz im ernst ich glaube es gibt wenige die dieses jahr nicht
minus haben ich habe dann 20 amazon aktien aha aha wahrscheinlich ja aktuell
habe ich eine
so also ich zeige euch jetzt mal was um was geht ob es abschließend funktioniert können
wir nicht ausprobieren weil der fernseher wird gerade verwendet oder vielleicht mache ich
einfach kaputt kakuate also ich war mal kurz meine nidox vm an ich zeige was der desktop ist
richtig massif poc komm mal du hast schon erst hier die richtigen emotes sind am start schon
wieder max 1 2 3 4 5 6 fack password leak
max wie findest du dich zurecht mache ich guck zum beispiel wo ist monka s monka
s ist da monka s 3 ist da ja ich finde alles auf meinem desktop außerdem ich benutze den
desktop gar nicht als desktop ihr seht habt ihr mich jemals im stream ok für projektideen
vielleicht das ist glaube ich das einzige was auch um dessen manchmal klingeln aber
ihr seht mich sehr selten im stream über den desktop program starten oder eigentlich nie also
ich benutze den desktop als ganz normaler ordner firefox an lusashen alten campbell
brauchen wir nicht also ich zeige euch mal was für alle die sich wissen ganz kurz ich
habe mir vor einer weile so einen linux fernseh receiver gekauft also das ist quasi das was man
so kennt so was was bei eurer oma auch steht bloß ein bisschen moderner und potenter gachi bass
total ja mit hdmi anschlüssen usb netzwerk festplatte drin ich benutze den aber nicht zum
streng ich benutze aber nicht direkt zum fernsehen gucken sondern ich benutze ihm zum aufnehmen und
streamen an ein android tv was dann am fernsehen hängt nee brauche ich nicht weil ich gucke keine
keine sender wo ich smartcards für brauche ich gucke gar nichts meine mutter guckt ich gucke
gar nichts die muss ich jetzt wollen wir gucken was sie guckt bestimmt rosamunde pilcher oder
so was kommen wir gucken mal was sie schaut leak leak weiß gar nicht ob man das sieht glaube
so ist es sieht man irgendwo was die schaut ne subscriptions die guckt die guckt immer ärger
mit grandpa was auch immer ich will es gar nicht wissen ich will ich interessiert mich nicht wichtig
ist der kram muss funktionieren dass ich nicht nach support gefragt werden also dass ich nicht
nach support gefragt werden der rest ist mir total egal genau richtig lustiger film für boomer ja so
also man sieht hier das ist und das ist das worum es eigentlich geht das hier ist eine tv headend
version von 2020 mit einem patch die ist relativ alt machen wir das in der cloud weil wir es
können nein und ja beides wir machen es in der cloud erstens weil wir es können und zweitens
was home assi was was für ein ding den zusammenhang verstehe ich nicht also das stand wohl home
assistant wo ach hier home assistant hier das meinst du das oder hier im tv headend irgendwo
ach mein lesezeichen ja ja ja wir haben home assistant paar mal im stream schon sehen so also
warum machen wir das in der cloud erstens weil wir es können und zweitens weil das ding sagt
es braucht mehrere stunden zu kompilieren weil wir brauchen eine komplette bildumgebung für
wir brauchen eine komplette bildumgebung für mein linux receiver und das müssen wir komplett
selbst übersetzen damit wir dann software übersetzen können also richtig six header
teilen ja wir müssen erstmal eine bildumgebung bilden damit wir dann software bilden können und
dann bilden wir tv headend so und ich habe ich habe also ihr seht mein tv headend ist alt
wir machen das auch nicht mit kubernetes wir machen das bei mit mit 16 core wie viel das
ist wirst du gleich sehen ich weiß es selbst nicht wir machen das anders wir hoffen wir mieten uns
bei hetsen ein 16 core 16 core 32 g oder so server den man stündlich abrechnet dann
bilde ich das da drauf und ziehst mir runter dann habe ich am ende 2 euro bezahlt oder so
keine ahnung vielleicht hast du irgendwelche studio plugins oder so
wollen wir mario spielen ja klar was welch was welche welches mario
eigentlich kannst du multiplayer doch nur wirklich mario party spielen oder oder mario card oder ja
gut vielleicht hatte hatte mario galaxy nicht sogar auch ein multiplayer oder zweite spieler mit der
remote sterne schießen konnte ne nicht sterben staub schießen konnte oder so da war noch was
ich erinnere mich aber das war nur lokal das war glaube ich nur lokal der explorer lag teilweise
schon rum ja aber es ist noch nicht genug auf dem desktop das problem kenne ich aber auf meinem
anderen desktop also nicht auf dem hier auf dem hier ist ja der desktop gar nicht richtig voll
aber auf man sieht schon beim markieren das ist das lag also auf meinem main account habe ich den
desktop so voll dass der desktop wahrscheinlich vier bis fünf mal voll ist und dann slowed dann
slowed down der explorer richtig so also was wollte ich euch jetzt zeigen und zwar ich habe
eine einen guide gefunden also hier auf meinem linux receiver läuft open a tv das ist eine
image für linux tv receiver warum wird nicht lokal kompiliert wirst du gleich sehen weil das
wohl ein bisschen zu lange dauert lokal so ich habe einen guide gefunden messif so und und der
sagt wie man das machen wenn so nicht ich habe mich da schon ein bisschen schlau gemacht das
ist mittlerweile deutlich einfacher wahrscheinlich ich fände lang schon für den sub danke leute
falls noch wer gesagt hat ich habe es dann habe ich übersehen ja falls ich ein bisschen schmatze
sorry ich muss gerade den bonbon nutzen wegen wegen hals und so wird 16 kerne da ausreichen
ich weiß es nicht ich hoffe es mal ist okay gatschi was dann so also gibt es eine anleitung
hier und wenn ich das richtig verstanden haben mittlerweile ist das etwas einfacher weil also
von der theorie was wir machen müssen ist folgendes wir müssen also das habe ich gerade laufen diesen
standard tv heaven so einfach den ich habe das von 2020 so also was ich gefunden habe ist ich habe
die offizielle image bauanleitung geführt gefunden für open a tv das geht so das werden wir gleich
machen und dann habe ich gesehen dieser typ hat wohl ein custom script zum bilden von tv heaven
in dem offiziellen oder weiß ich vermute ich in dem in dem mehr oder weniger offiziellen repo
drinne also das was der hier gemacht hat gibt es schon als fertiges bild script hier guckt da ich
habe keine ahnung was ich hier mache ich habe auch keine ahnung ob es funktioniert ich habe
auch keine ahnung also ob man das machen sollte ja ich habe dafür noch nie was gebaut ich habe
keinen plan so und der typ hat irgendwie anscheinend hier ein bild script hinterlegt wie auch immer
man das genau verwendet ich ich vermute ich vermute so bit bake und dann was man bauen will ich habe
ich habe keinen plastenschimmer so deswegen würde ich sagen wir legen uns erstmal eine cloud kiste
an und zwar was fettes als server wo gehen wir hin nürnberg nur im sorry nur nur im berg nur im
berg geben ubuntu 204 das braucht man ubuntu 20 04 weil das steht in der offiziellen bild
anleitung von openart tv dass die ubuntu oder sorry nicht ubuntu sondern wir müssen das wir
müssen es korrekt aufsprechen dass man 20 04 nehmen soll gut gut dass wir jetzt mittlerweile
die passenden emotes haben da so und was mich etwas also warum wir das in der cloud machen ich
zeige es euch jetzt und zwar weil hier steht wir brauchen mindestens 16 gigabyte ram und möglichst
viele kerne und viel ssd speicher und was mich wirklich schockiert hat ist diese aussage bild
an image bild time 5 bis 12 stunden und ein minimal image 1 bis 2 stunden da dachte ich mir
so ich glaube es ist keine gute idee das lokal zu machen ich glaube es ist gut das auf einer
fetten krautkiste zu machen auf sowas hier zum beispiel 16 kerne 32 geram hatten die noch hatten
die nicht noch noch fettere wie das hat einen limit das ist neu das ist das ist das ist in der
tarte neu oder ist das was weil es insgesamt keine mehr gibt chat ist das ist was meint ihr
ist es ein limit auf meinem account oder ist das ein limit weil die gerade keine server mehr frei
haben wie kann sowas aber das das ist noch nicht lange ich weiß noch wir haben mal wir haben mal
open street maps wir haben mal open street maps pre processed und stimmt vielleicht gucken wir
mal ein faltenstein ob das auch so ist ja und hell sinkie ist es wahrscheinlich auch so ja das
ist account geschichte da hatten wir glaube ich die 48 48 vor kisten scheint egal ganz im ernst 16
course 32 geram 360 gigabyte ssd sollte auch reichen kiste kostet 60 euro im monat aber wir
brauchen sie wahrscheinlich nur eins zwei stunden also am ende am ende irgendwie zwei euro oder so
knapp nicht zwei euro die schwache nicht zwei euro 0,2 euro dann in zwei stunden also das ist
nix ok also wir erzeugen meine cloud kiste aber nicht keine firewall test test test oder max max
ad poggers guter key glaubt nehmen wir jetzt so Ubuntu kiste erstellen 32 gb so und nebenbei
während während die sich erstellt ich liege jetzt mal die ip ich weiß es gibt wahrscheinlich
lustige leute die gleich dann die ab den server die dorsten aber ganz im ernst zu kerst da
löscht den server halt und dann was will ich machen ich habe jetzt kein bock das alles zu
verschleiern was ich aber mache ist für das basic setup wir hatten doch mal irgendwo ein
insiple script wo hatte man das ansieble playbooks genau das brauche ich
ab wie einfach so wie das war es jetzt
base so was haben wir noch in unserem insiple playbook noch mal drinnen so testserver
ne ne das wollen wir nicht was kann man rausschmeißen in dem fall root htp htps mqtt ja das ist ziemlich
sinnlos ssh wollen wir erlauben mit der ufw sonst nix ja nur ssh muss mal kurz unser setup kurz
einrichten so ufw enable update upgrade install basic packages kein prometoise exporter oder
sonstigen shit das brauche man nicht das braucht doch kein mensch auch kein kadi drauf und auch
kein ssl kein mensch alles nicht weg damit leute wir hatten doch irgendwo was wo wir ssh so
eingerichtet haben dass ich nicht meine ip geliegt habe wo haben wir denn das weil ansonsten muss
ich jetzt euch ausschalten das login einschalten dass das das ip logging ausschalten und dann
einloggen weil wir wissen dass sich die leute nicht zurückhalten können war das vielleicht
einen anderen ordner ok fein ansible aha guck mal da keks to do ansible vielleicht da oder
in angel def ops scrum infra wir haben so viel so viel schwachsinn hier schon gemacht ok gucken
wir mal hier rein server jammel vielleicht attino danke für den sub dennis danke für den sub
da deploy ssh hier print last lock das meine ich das das meine ich ok was wisst ihr was
gleich den ganzen temple das brauchen wir nie wieder außerdem habe ich das glaube ich
damals sogar auf github gepusht alles weg so das ist das das ist das eigentliche was ich machen
wollte dass ich beim login dass ich nichts liege so perfekt exzellent so also ip vom server da
in richtung jetzt ein oder mal ein bisschen kommt compile action drauf playbook text deploy also
server der da server jammel passt yes but fail to connect zu haus ja du sollst dich auch nicht mit
mit max drauf connecten sondern mit user root ist es ist es user wie weg ne was permission was
ich sag bloß sag bloß der ssh geht nicht ja ich habe ihn leute ich habe irgendeinen random key
ausgewählt ich habe keine ahnung ob ich den key überhaupt noch hab nur weil er da drinnen
stehen muss ja noch lange nicht sein dass der kürtig ist als johi danke für den sub ich fürchte
wir müssen selber nochmal löschen ich weiß nicht ob ich den richtigen ssh key habe so hier fette
kiste nehmen wir mal den ich oder oder max der poggers zwei kann man nicht mehrere auswählen
ich erde einfach alle ssh keys einfach alle ssh keys drauf bm wird schon funktionieren ist nicht
gut bei ubuntu doch beim hetsner ubuntu ist es gut normalerweise nicht hast du recht normalerweise
gehst du bei ubuntu drauf und machst dann sudo aber beim hetsner ubuntu ist es gut das weiß ich
das ist gut das ist auf jeden fall normalerweise ist es nicht so das stimmt so
ach guck mal wir haben wir die gleiche ip gekriegt wie vorher pock pock chamber
host key verification fail ja gut das ist kein host key keygen-r bm playbook gib ihm yes so und
jetzt warten wir kurz bis das server basic eingerichtet ist und dann loggen wir uns
darauf ein und versuchen den kram zu kompilieren also was man machen muss ist wie gesagt normal
du hast schon recht ms ist normalerweise ist das unter ubuntu so das wird das muss ich einmal
im monat bezahlen man kriegt eine rechnung man kann auch pre man kann auch aufladen und so art
prepaid machen aber ich krieg einmal im monat eine rechnung muss muss es bezahlen normalerweise hast
du recht also normalerweise hast du keine root login unter ubuntu hetsner nicht heiße aber ich
weiß was gemeint ist ja pepe please musik
nächstes mal vor allem mit terraform erstellen könnte man machen es gibt also dass der hetsner
ist so ported no grott dankeschön no no grott ich weiß nicht wie man es ausspricht aber dankeschön
für den primes ab warum sieht bei dir die vm so krass aus wenn ich eine feier mit feier
workstation pro erstelle ist die sie null vergleichbar mit dem normalen pc von der
performance vor allem design ist alles ja gut das liegt daran dass ich in den teilen
window manager verwende das ist halt relativ relativ performant weil da nix irgendwie großartig
animiert gerendert sonst was muss es alles statisch die einzige transparenz ich habe
es hier oben in meiner leiste ach ja und was wichtig ist du musst der vm auch ordentlich
wums rein stecken ja also sprich ich habe den t hat er bei mir vier cpu kerne 128 g ssd 16
gigabyte ram volle dankeschön für den zapp für die 30 milliaren bilds noch besser tinti
massive 13 monats subscription bingo hat ein zapp er hat kein zapp gegift hat gesappt weil
irgendjemand gesagt hat pock ich habe das zapp gegift ne dankeschön für den zapp mit
etwas für hat ja ich ich stelle auch demnächst irgendwelche remote templates bereit die man
sich dann abrufen kann so und jetzt sollte eigentlich alles eingerichtet sein ich kann
mich auf die vm connecten und in der hoffnung nicht meine ip zu leaken die das no he lacks
critical information es hat funktioniert ich habe nicht meine ip geliegt also die ip vom
server aber gut was soll es ja gut also sehr schön so sind wir auf der kiste drauf jetzt
machen wir mal die offizielle bild umgebungs bild also das bild für die bild umgebung so
wie es in der offiziellen anleitung drinne steht kann man eigentlich nein kannst du nicht
ach so ja das funktioniert wiederum wenn du ein bisschen advancedere sachen machst und
schaust ob man nicht vielleicht die grafikkarte durchreicht wobei du dann wiederum für deinen
haust eine zweite grafikkarte brauchst also kannst zum beispiel die on-board grafikkarte
für den haus nehmen und deine nvidia karte in die vm weiterreichen was es geht auch eine
aber nee es kann nicht eine gehen also du kannst es so machen dass es freigegeben wird
aber wie soll denn das funktionieren wie willst du denn
kann so nicht die grafikkarte in deine windows vm durchreichen ja moment das meine ich doch
nicht wenn du beides an hast du hast auch beides an du hast die vm an und du hast den haust
an da kannst du doch nicht gleichzeitig die grafikkarte im haust und in der vm verwenden
dass du das dass du das anbinden kannst ja aber das macht doch noch mal das das macht
auch so eine 0815 grafikkarte nicht ich kenne das dass die bei nvidia bei den ganz teuren
haben die so virtualisierungs zeug drinne was zum beispiel von von von hyper wie zum beispiel
unterstützt wird aber das macht doch so irgendwie so 0815 desktop grafikkarte nicht nvidia
sowas da zum beispiel
nee ist sr eo v sr eo v ist doch das beim netzwerk oder nennt sich das bei grafikkarten
auch so also bei netzwerkarten habe ich das schon gesehen dass man zum beispiel aus einer
intel server netzwerkarte irgendwie bis zu zwölf oder so machen kann dass es dann wirklich
für die vm so aussieht komplett ohne dass sie das mitbekommt denkt er hat eine eigene
durchgereichte netzwerkarte ja gut dann musste die vm aber starten und stoppen wenn du es
auf dem host haben willst ja host läuft hetles weiter nee ich meine dass man host und vm verwenden
kann und sowas wie looking class kann man verwenden ja aber wenn wir beim thema sind
das ist nicht so nicht so easy ja also es geht aber es ist nicht so einfach so wir machen
jetzt mal weiter also wo sind wir stehen geblieben erstmal den bild für den bild installieren
wir machen vorher mal einen tmax das brauchen wir bestimmt hardtop des des und shit installieren
wie alles schon drauf warum ist doch schon alles drauf moment habe ich war das in unserem
ansatz script drinne vielleicht haben wir das im ansatz script ja keine ahnung ok also
wir installieren das mal beim oder haben die in ihrem base im mit schon sinnvolle sachen
drinne dass wir feife da klaut nur sichtbar für dich steht grad bei mir im chat du hast
alle level 1 emotes gesammelt bedeutet dass wir brauchen einen subtrain einen einen subs
gemma's train der über level 1 rausgeht öfters mal da will ich keinen zu an anhalten
es sei denn ihr wollt besaß nächsten raumflug mitfinanzieren ich freue mich trotzdem in
spaß bei natürlich freue ich mich über jeden zapp aber ich freue mich auch über
jeden zuschauer wenn ihr samen wollt wunderbar kann man einmal im monat kostenlos machen
gerade wenn ihr prime habt aber ich freue mich auch wenn ihr einfach da seid white people
so happy wie das ging jetzt relativ zackig ok gleich mal teamaxe session starten wie
gehts weiter set python 3 as preferred provider als da ich führe das einfach wie der letzte
kakku der reihe nach aus und dann gucken wir was passiert update alternatives und jetzt
select python 3 also ich muss 2 selecten oh das das ist auch schon wieder excellent du
musst 2 eingeben dass du python 3 selectest sehr schön so und jetzt reconfigure your shell
was select no ich selekte no alles klar watch ach so ja gut das ist dass er mehrere dateien
gleichzeitig aufmachen kann und und überwachen kann ok das verstehe ich das ist sinnvoll
add new user open a tv bilder ich will eigentlich keinen neuen user adden da muss ich dem user
nämlich ein kreides passwort geben weil ansonsten sind die hacker manns am starten versuchen
sich einzuloggen mit dem neuen user ok ich muss mir ich muss mir jetzt kurz ein passwort
ausdenken was ihr nicht erraten können weiß nämlich nicht ob der ob der user im ssh aktiviert
ist ok ok ich habe was ich habe was
ja ich weiß aber ich weiß aus dem kopf nicht wie man kann es mit disabled login und so
was anlegen ich weiß weiß ich aber gar nicht wie es geht so aber so ist auch ok also wie
geht es weiter wie geht es weiter ok ich werde dieser user create folder open a tv 7 switch
in folder gut clone oe alliance repo wer genau ist die oe alliance oe alliance member jetzt
weiß ich bescheid chat obvious das ist die oe alliance wie kann man die nicht kennen
oe alliance open enigma alliance heißt das bestimmt weil enigma nennt sich doch dieses
ganze linux tv tuner zeug das ist bestimmt das ist bestimmt das heißt bestimmt open
enigma alliance die sind so die sind ne nein nein open embedded alliance ok fast fast ok
die oe im betten was alter da soll mal einer durchblicken ist auch egal wir wollen sachen
kompilieren gut ist so schön jetzt haben wir eine vm und du bild environment make update
wir melken update bitte da ist es hier guck mal bitbake sache mal chat nur in das ausgedreht
hat jemand von euch sowas in der richtung schon mal gemacht also falls es jetzt gleich
überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat irgendeiner plan von weil ich habe wirklich keine ahnung
was ich hier überhaupt mache ich mache die anleitung durch und bis jetzt funktioniert
es normalerweise täglich natürlich glaube ich dir sofort obvious jeder cringe wer das
nicht täglich macht was das wird ich versuche was für meinen tv receiver zu cross kompilen
warum musst du selber bauen ah doch das gibt es fertig chillfreak aber in der alten version
fertig gibt es das mit einer version von 2020 aber ich will was neues haben aus einem praktischen
grund und eigentlich hauptsächlich weil ich mal gucken will wie das funktioniert heute
ist nicht so ganz korrekt so und jetzt wie geht es weiter wir haben den kram geupdatet
ne aber das update habe ich jetzt schon gemacht mit update ja ok update finally you can bild
in image ok leute wir machen vielleicht nicht das 5 bis 12 stunden bild oder das könnte
das könnte auch auf einer super fetten cloud kiste vielleicht ein bisschen lange dauern
ne wir machen nicht das 12 stunden bild wir machen das 1 bis 2 stunden bild und ich hoffe
dass es in der cloud in keine ahnung mehr viertel stunde geht wie viele course hat
max 16 so machine da muss ich mir jetzt raussuchen für meine für meine box garantiert weil
diese box habe ich nicht wo sieht man dann was es für boxen gibt v u plus oder so suchen
woher weiß ich denn was es da alles gibt keine ahnung v u plus was ist das viel zeug also
das viel zeug ist quasi dass das das das repo das nennt das das ist das was bei debian
standardmäßig auf die debian repos zeigt ist bei openart tv der feed warum es dort
feed heißt und nicht repo ich habe keine ahnung ich muss rausbekommen wie die box heißt
die ich hab ah guck mal hier machine v u uno aber ich hab keine v u uno ich hab eine v
u uno 4k se ach guck mal hier gibt es eine liste ähm die software ist in python unten
drunter dieses enigma zeug aber die eigentlichen pakete die müssen schon übereinstimmen weil
die aldi box ist wahrscheinlich keine armbox also du musst schon die richtige du musst
das schon für die richtige box kompilieren so hier uno 4k se ob das sagt mal meint ihr
das ist die gewollte art sich rauszusuchen oder gibt es in den make befehl make list
machine oder so das wäre vielleicht nicht schlecht wenn die das irgendwo hinschreiben
würden ok also wie geht es weiter so das ist meine box das ist meine box und was muss ich
jetzt machen doku plotet genau hier feinlich also wir machen mal das image was zwei stunden
äh was was angeblich für zwei stunden dauert und wir machen hier unten mal auf wir machen
hier unten mal hardtop auf und gucken wie die cpu auslastung ist ich meine wir haben
eine ziemlich fette kiste wir haben die fetteste kiste die ich gerade mit meinem account erstellen
konnte woops 16 kerne also es müsste ein bisschen schneller gehen ok vu soll ich es
lieber klein schreiben meint ihr das macht einen unterschied v1 4k se ok habe ich alle
schritte gemacht vorher update habe ich gemacht was machen wir wir versuchen eine neue tv
headend version für meinen tv receiver zu kompilieren make-j da habe ich keinen einfluss
drauf oder ach doch hier hat das einen grund warum ich 32 nehmen soll ich meine ich habe
nur 16 kerne ich meine die müssen warten öfters mal weil man doch einfach 16 oder oder wir
gucken mal wir gucken mal was der default mäßig macht vielleicht macht er ja schon 16 oder
32 ok ich führe aus checking internet connection ah bäm ordentlich cpu auslastung da geht's
rund ok der sarix hat schon mal wieder richtig pfeife etwas rausgesucht mehr ist nicht schneller
ja dann brauche ich auch nicht mehr dann war mal 16 wobei es sieht so aus als hätte der
16 kerne oder wie will das ding sonst so auslassen du bist mir entfolgt was ist da los habe ich
dich vielleicht aus versehen mal gebannt und dann entfolgt ein follow das oder so ich banne
ja manchmal aus versehen leute weil ich mich im chat verklickt kann man nur sagen keck
bei dem uns ich mache kein 7 tv ich habe kein 7 tv was macht er denn da eigentlich
jetzt leute moment moment sehe ich das richtig das funktioniert einfach so geht das einfach
jetzt das glaube ich erst wenn er fertig kompilieren ist weird champ wenn das einfach gehen würde
das wäre ein komplett unerwarteter nahezu unhaltbarer zustand dass du einfach eine anleitung
durchklickst und am ende klappt das also das kann ich sein da kommen noch irgendwelche
patch errors compile fehler oder sonst was wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich wenn er auch
mal dazu gerne jeder hat sogar anzeige ich wollte nämlich gerade sagen wahrscheinlich
wenn der von und dann habe ich gesehen dass er angeblich schon fertig ist mit den packages
wahrscheinlich ist er dann bei 800 bei 8000 packages und und sagt dann irgendwann fehler
oder so
aber die auslastung ist ordentlich
wisst ihr was wir parallel machen ich glaube die kiste ist noch nicht genug ausgelastet
ich glaube ich mache mir noch einen zweiten ordner und weil hier kompiliere ich jetzt
ja quasi das basis themen und hier unten haben wir an ich kann mir keine größere
kiste besorgen ich habe die fetteste kiste die meine account hergibt gerade ich weiß
nicht genau warum ich auf einmal ein limit habe ich habe immer bezahlt und wir hatten
auch schon mal die 48 keine kiste hier vielleicht haben die aber die default limits runter gesetzt
kann ja sein ich habe meinen account bei hetze nämlich immer noch nach nach über fünf
jahren nicht authentifiziert mit mit ausweis und so also ich will ich will ja auch mal ausweis
nicht schicken aber ich meine ich benutze das schon ewig und ich bezahle immer pünktlich
also ich kann eigentlich nichts gegen mich haben
hier haben wir mich auch eine anlage wie man specific packages bilden kann wir machen einfach
jetzt noch einen zweiten su
hier ist der ordner wo gerade mkdir temp beste ordnername wir machen jetzt einfach noch mal
was anderes parallel so ich clone den shit noch mal wo ist es wo ist das wo ist das report
zum klonen da klonen wir mal in anderen ordner noch mal rein und jetzt versuche ich das da
unten mal und gucke ob ich überhaupt tv hat ein theoretisch kompilieren könnte also ob
er das überhaupt findet wie viele server du erstellen kannst ich oder es ist die fq oder
es ist die fq was ich weiß dass man das stellen kann aber ich hatte schon mal und das kann
ich kann ich euch sogar zeigen wir hatten nämlich im stream mal open streetmaps preprocessed
guckt mal archief archief wo bloß punkt tv tv street open und warum ist es da nicht
drin map ach karten maps mit monka javascript nee das ist was anderes
das ist was anderes nee das das war der amazon das war der tracker den man mal gebaut
haben ich habe den ich habe den stream ich habe den stream wahrscheinlich gelöscht
weil ich irgendwas geleakt habe oder so wahrscheinlich ist das deswegen nicht wahrscheinlich ist
das deswegen nicht drin kann schon sein so wie weit ist er der brummt leute guck mal
das geht verhältnismäßig schnell also das dauert keine stunde hier wenn es in dem tempo
weiter geht ok aber ich wollte ja mal was anderes ausprobieren also nee was was wir jetzt machen
cd bild environment make update noch mal das haben wir zwar gerade schon gemacht aber in
einem anderen ordner und dann müssen wir bild specific packages da machen wir mal das und
gucken ob man überhaupt theoretisch tv hat entbilden kann oder ob ich mir hier irgendwas
ob ich irgendwas hiervon machen muss ob das funktioniert aber ich finde das gut wie ihr
das macht mit der archivseite also erstens leute da müssen wir jetzt mal ganz kurz an
der stelle den serious max beziehungsweise auch mal die anderen mods aber der serious
max programmiert und sagen dass sie das wirklich gut gemacht haben und wir wirklich poggers
mods haben ich meine wir gibt auf twitch wette ich mit euch eine handvoll streamer die mods
haben die sowas wie das watt archiv programmieren können weil das ist komplett custom gemacht
ich glaube ich weiß nicht ob du in den template für das für das html nee für das css verwendet
hast keine ahnung aber es sieht jetzt ja auch nicht so super komplex aus hast bestimmt selbst
gemacht guck mal es gibt sogar das archiv gibt sogar auf github kann man sogar starren wenn
man will das archiv gehört zur age progers foundation ach bootstrap ok holster habe ich
vor jahren mal benutzt wüsste ich gar nicht wie die klasse heißen ja also richtig richtig
poc g also hier haben wir den kram untergeladen jetzt probieren ob man tv tv header theoretisch
kompilieren könnte also was musste man machen vuno 4 kse make init und dann cd builds ach
nee vuno müsste das sein ok source enf echt poc so ein archiv ja und jetzt kann ich sagen
bitbake nfs utils jetzt weiß ich wenn man jetzt bitbake tv header add und wenn das so
easy funktioniert wie ich mir das denke müsste jetzt versuchen einfach tv her zu kompilieren
heute die ausbildung zum fisi abgeschlossen dazu habe ich irgendwie habe ich irgendwie
ein ein applaus sound oder sowas sowas habe ich glaube ich gar nicht oder ja aber nice
easy clap war easy clap oder wie war die abschlussprüfung was oder was ein bisschen schwieriger
ist ja ja ja sie haben wir ja genau ihr könnt im archiv könnt ihr sie umschalten also für
die richtigen cute cute bunto fans cute sie ja
so
alle 16 kerne ich warte kurz mit dem zweiten kompil vorgang das ding ist ja am limit
der chat ist da vorne man sieht doch alles ich habe keine eingabe zeilen hier unten das meinste
ok das das ist doof ihr seht das tatsächlich das ist ja weil es auch wieder so ein ewig super
langes ding ist also was ich hier hinten eingegeben habe ihr werdet gleich sehen ist bitbake bitbake
ich machs bisschen kleiner guck mal hier massive bitbake tv headend habe ich ja eingegeben sobald
der anfängt ist der chat auch nicht mehr davor aber ich will gerade keinen zweiten kompil vorgang
starten weil der ist ziemlich ausgelastet gerade aber ich mein hey ich bezahle für 16 cpu kerne
warum soll ich weniger verwenden stimmt chat ich bin doof guck mal ich könnte ich könnte einfach
das ganze splitten oder so machen oder sowas ja dann seht ihr es wieder oder so ja die denken
dass ich meine vielleicht ist es verboten hat jetzt noch was in der fhk stehen ob manigen
erlaubt ist oder nicht mal ganz davon abgesehen es lohnt sich wahrscheinlich auch überhaupt nicht
ist verboten ja ist auch richtig so ist auch unsinnig aber mal davon abgesehen ich glaube
es lohnt sich auch gar nicht wie es noch mal wie es noch mal diese kryptowährung mit den
festplatten chia oder so gell chia chia chia doch richtig chia wir gucken mal den kurs wir
gucken mal kurz den kurs ok ok es interessiert sich keiner mehr für chia die halbzeit ging es
voll ab das war das auch wo der bauer mal ein video zugemacht hat zugemacht hat und ja krasser
dip das ist ja fast schon game stop aktie wenn die jetzt noch mal hoch geht
ja übrigens jetzt wo ich das ding das koppium emotes sehe ich habe mir ich habe mir auch so
ein koppium gerät gekauft weil ich habe festgestellt wenn ich halsweh habe hilft das dann mache ich
eine runde koppium und dann dann ist besser bloß bei mir ist es im endeffekt einfach nur
salzwasser boah der haut aber schon rein was der an cpu last macht moment gtk 3 was macht
der denn da warum warum braucht der gta 3 ähnlich gta gtk 3 warum braucht der gtk 3 doch doch es
gibt einen fortschrittsbalken der fortschrittsbalken ist da guck mal hier hier 40 prozent und 3000 3000 von
8000 packages ein kalt inhaliergerät korrekt warum braucht der gtk 3 das ist ein headless tv tuner
linux receiver warum brauchen die gui krempel als nächstes fehlt noch chrome ich sag euch als
nächstes installieren die noch webkit und chrome oder so da wäre ich jetzt würde mich
nichts mehr wundern ok wir machen jetzt folgendes wir warten jetzt mal kurz noch ein paar minuten
bis sich das hier wieder beruhigt hat und dann werfe ich das tv header kompilieren an weil soweit
ich das verstanden habe ist das ja nur das base image und ich kann wohl parallel was anderes für
die packages kompilieren aber in der anleitung steht ich sollte das base package ich sollte das
also in dieser anleitung steht drin ich sollte das base image einmal kompilieren um zu gucken ob
die config die ich habe funktioniert steht hier irgendwo drin base image oder irgendwo hier steht
das drin ja hier steht steht drin dass man das image mal bilden soll und gucken ob das funktioniert
pass auf bei 99 prozent kompiliere ich glaube es auch genau um sie was zum webkit webkit alter
wollte mich verarschen webkit da fällt mir gar nichts dazu ein was kommt als nächstes
oder was was kommt als nächstes wtf webkit warum warum kompiliert ihr webkit gleich kommt
chrome also wenn jetzt weiß ich warum das zwölf stunden dauert wenn die chrome kompilieren das
dauert zwölf stunden chrome kompilieren ist das abartig ist was du machen kannst wir haben
das mal probiert ich habe es aufgegeben chrome kompilieren braucht 2 terabyte ram und und 50
petabyte festplatten platz und was noch alles kompilierst du auch die guten treiber von der tv
karte mit rein ich hoffe ich hoffe dass er das macht ich hoffe ich habe keine ahnung aber davon
abgesehen ich brauche keine treiber für die tv karte weil also zwei sachen moment also zwei
sachen ich benutze satt alpi also lokal auf der kiste ich mache auf satt alpi auf local host das
heißt mein tv hat muss gar nicht direkt mit dem mit den tunern interagieren sondern mit satt
alpi und das zweite ist die treiber sind ja schon dabei tv hat entspricht die ganz normalen dvb
treiber in die lux an also ich brauche da eigentlich gar keine extra treiber und falls du
treiber für diese proprietären vu plus dinger meinst die gibt es gar nicht die gibt es nur im
40 image alles irgendwelcher klaus gar mit uns konnte noch keiner hinbekommen hat auch keine
hinbekommen der views welche web views das ding ist ein headless linux receiver welche web views
ach meinst du vielleicht im du hast recht das könnte sein in dem eigentlichen gui was ich
nicht verwende in der in der in der fernsehoberfläche vielleicht das könnte tatsächlich sein ja das
wird wahrscheinlich so sein ist dir warum ich weiß warum die webkit drauf machen die haben
seit neuesten seit neuestem kannst du auch youtube auf der box gucken und youtube läuft in einem
browser da drauf deswegen webkit ja die haben dann webview drauf aber mal ganz davon abgesehen
mich interessiert das null ich habe die box ja gar nicht am fernseher angeschlossen ich
ich streame von der box auf einen android tv was am fernseher angeschlossen ist warum chrome
kompilieren nee muss man nicht muss man nicht es gibt verrückte die machen das aber muss ein
always on vpn mit domänenverwaltung einrichten hast du sowas schon mal gemacht irgendwelche
tips für mich was musst du machen also was hat das eine mit dem anderen zu tun oder meinst
ne du meinst du du meinst quasi sowas wie wie wie den vpn von von und zu in einem cloud anbieter
oder sowas dass du quasi dann mit den cloud vms auf deine internen server connecten kannst
und von dein internen server auf die cloud vms oder sowas oder oder oder was also nee sowas
habe ich noch nicht gemacht ich habe ich habe schon vpn gemacht ja sowohl mit ipsec als auch
mit open vpn oder neuerdings auch mit wireguard aber die sind in der regel always on ansonsten
wüsste ich nicht was da aber was ist was ist was das mit domänenverwaltung zu tun hat verstehe
ich nicht das ist so chrome übrigens chrome ich habe meine statistik gesehen chrome hat
glaube ich mittlerweile dreimal so viele source code zeilen wie windows kein spaß die letzte
in der statistik gesehen ich glaube hat sogar einer von microsoft gepostet chrome hat irgendwie
3,3 genießt das wirklich mit vorsicht die zahlen die ich euch jetzt sage das ist alles
so irgendwo mittag ich glaube chrome hat 3,5 oder 4,5 millionen zeilen source code oder
sowas und windows nur irgendwie 1,5 millionen oder so irgendwie also es ist auf jeden fall
heftig chrome ist quasi komplexer als das komplette komplette betriebssystem
das kann jeder du kannst du ich hätte dir sagen können du hättest ausrufezeichen hetzen
im start machen können im chat machen können mit 20 eur startguthaben zu sichern aber das
geht nicht mehr das ging nur bis ende letzten jahres und ich habe mit hettest dieses jahr
noch nichts weiteres vereinbart das kann jeder stündlich abrechnen der fairness halber sei
gesagt die meisten cloud anbieter bieten das an da ist jetzt nicht alleine aber ich finde
der preis leistungsmäßig trotzdem ziemlich gut
microsoft heißt das always on muss vom rechenzentrum aus mit dem domain controller die kunden kleines
wir waren beziehungsweise immer always on vpn verwalten und die infraschon mit hyper wieder
ok keine ahnung das ist windows krempel ich habe kein schimmer ansonsten also linux technisch
würde ich das anders machen ich meine keine ahnung wie man das mit windows macht aber
windows technisch würde ich also linux technisch würde ich keinen keinen keinen dauerhaften
tunnel von mir zu den kleines offen haben im zweifelsfall wird ein rechner mal gehackermant
und alle deine kunden sind dann betroffen ja gibt verschiedene möglichkeiten ja du kannst
irgendeinen hopp surfer für ssh bauen unter linux du kannst alternativ auch so machen
dass das reverse geht dass die die verbindung initial initiieren oder du nimmst irgendein
anders geartete tunnelgeschichte am besten auch mit zwei fakte autentifizierung zumindest
initial also gibt es jede menge sachen aber so mit windows habe ich keine ahnung kannst
du dir vorstellen warum das so ist chrome was das windows ja kann ich mir vorstellen
weil browser mittlerweile eine unglaublich komplexe angelegenheit sind und browser ja
quasi alles das oder alles ist jetzt übertrieben aber vieles von dem was windows macht selbst
implementieren und noch mal mitbringen und das so dass es cross platform läuft zum beispiel
chrome muss komplett audio video zeug selbst machen chrome kann sich nicht darauf verlassen
auf die funktionen die das betriebssystem bietet chrome macht audio video selbst unter anderem
mit ffm pack und dann so dass cross platform linux mac windows android ios sorry ios ich
vergaß ich hab ich hab's vergessen es gibt ja gar kein chrome auf ios ist ja alles safari
skin und das auch so dass es cross platform funktionieren und es ist so viel neues zeugs
was da auch permanent dabei kommt von javascript standards bis neue sachen wie web gpu zählen
die ffm pack zu den chrome zeilen mit ich glaube nicht ich weiß nicht wie sie das ok
wir gucken einfach mal chrome lines of code es ist noch mehr geworden
guck mal die cry die cry engine 2 hat nur so wenig
google chrome und moment was das für eine was das für eine bescheuerte statistik das
geht auch was ganz anderes all internet services was das für blödsinn
das hat doch mit der sache gar nichts zu tun
erkennt man alles klar excellent super high res high res bild
pacify res ich kann es nicht mal lesen eine güde ok also aber chrome hat aktuell 6,7
millionen zeilen code das ist richtig heftig also wer da guck mal je nachdem was man mit
zielt ist es noch deutlich mehr es wird noch viel mehr es ist es ist wahnsinn also das
ist ein eigenes betriebssystem und noch mehr
es ist wahrscheinlich die frage wie man es zählt aber es ist wirklich ein eigenes also
chrome ist quasi komplexer als betriebssysteme ist aber auch logisch ich meine was da alles
dazu gehört und was die alles neu implementieren müssen allein schon überlegt euch mal überlegt
euch mal was es für ein abfuck sein muss dass du schaffst dass dein browser unter x11 ordentlich
angezeigt wird mac und windows dass das performant und ordentlich aussieht allein nur das gui
das ist schon da würde ich den würde ich meinen computer aus dem fenster schmeißen
wenn ich sowas machen muss ich würde wahrscheinlich würde ich nicht mal ansatzweise hinbekommen
gerade für x11 alter wer will für x11 irgendwas entwickeln und ich bin mir nicht mal sicher
ob chrome oder also firefox hatte ursprünglich mal irgendwie ein bisschen was mit gtk zu
tun unter linux ich glaube aber mittlerweile ist also bin mir relativ sicher bei chrome
war es noch nie so die haben wirklich native native zeug gebastelt die werden auch sowas
machen gehe ich mal davon aus ich gehe davon aus dass es dass das chrome fenster irgendein
mehr nicht 3d kontext ist also die werden das selbst malen hier drin also die der button
hier im chrome ich rate jetzt ich weiß nicht ob das so ist die buttons hier im chrome werden
nicht die gleichen buttons sein wie man jetzt beispielsweise hier in in einem windows programm
findet das ist alles selbst gerendert selbst gemalt das muss aber auch sein ne ne ne deshalb
frisken kommen nicht so viel rab das liegt an anderen gründen das ist theoretisch sogar
relativ effizient das ist nicht schlimm wenn man die sachen selber malt der riesen vorteil
wenn du deine gui sachen selber zeichnest ist es sieht halt überall so aus wie du willst
und und wenn du unten drunter das quasi dieses rendering implementiert hast läuft es halt
auch überall drauf es hört sich jetzt so einfach an ist es nicht macht das bar macht
es mal für x für x so was ist hier los jetzt fertig kompilieren nee er ist nicht fertig
kompilieren warum nicht weil er hängt beim download alter da habe ich jetzt nicht mit
gerechnet dass irgendein download so lahm ist guckt euch das mal an ok da können wir jetzt
das andere machen mit back tv her dann machen wir jetzt auf geht's wir probieren einfach
direkt tv her dann zu kompilieren und gucken ob das funktioniert ich glaube nicht dass
ich rate limited bin ne quatsch hetzer drossel an der stelle nix hätte verlangt glaube ich
auch nicht mal geld für moment warte mal eingehender traffic ist kostenlos oder ausgehender
traffic ist kostenlos also traffic ist bis 20 bis 20 gigabyte e kostenlos aber ich glaube
ausgehender ausgehender traffic ist kostenlos ja also du hast bei 20 gigabyte traffic frei
das ist terabyte nicht gigabyte null gigabyte wäre ja nix terabyte 20 terabyte traffic frei
und eins davon ist auch noch unlimited also guck mal wie das flutscht guck mal hier wobei
das ist tibet der hängt am ende auch wieder bei 1000 packages rum
die cpu ist nicht ausgelassen aktuell kompiliert er ja auch noch nix oder nix großartiges sondern
er ist hauptsächlich am downloaden ku emu ne ne ku emu ist nicht dabei ku emu braucht
er um das cross zu kompilen oder keine ahnung warum ist ku emu dabei du kannst arm arm
gedöns auch ohne ku emu cross kompilen aber vielleicht ist es einfacher vielleicht vielleicht
braucht er das zum armen zum kompilieren von armen packages den den ku emu das könnte
sein gerade einfach ich habe mir die bildscripts nicht angeguckt ok die auslastung sieht schon
mal besser aus jetzt jetzt brummt es wieder ein bisschen was genau ist kompilieren wenn
du deinen source code so übersetzt dass du ihn ausführen kannst die mini erklärung
dafür wenn du aus deinem source code was ausführbares machst und ja wenn man ganz
korrekt sein will gibt es da zig verschieden unterschritte und es ist so auch nicht ganz
korrekt aber in der kurzfassung passt das schon du wandelst ein source code um in was
was man ausführen kann also in ein programm was man benutzen kann ja wenn man anfängt
sich das genauer anzugucken dann kommt erstmal die unterschied zwischen ja ist es vielleicht
was was noch ne runtime braucht ist es vielleicht irgendwas interpretiertes wo du dann noch
irgendeinen interpret dafür brauchst mittlerweile ist es ja gar nicht mehr so einfach diese
trennung zu machen weil die sachen sich überschneiden ja guckt man sich zum beispiel mal javascript
an javascript ist ich glaube mittlerweile alles drei mittlerweile ist javascript interpretiert
dann just in time compiled und dann irgendwie noch mal weiter optimiert also das kann man
alles gar nicht mehr so wie das früher war noch so sauber trennen hast du das neue lohnt
sich das video eingeschaut nein aber ich habe es aufgemacht hier das da können wir uns
nachher noch angucken elf minuten können wir bevor wir im bettel gehen wenn das kompilieren
jetzt mal funktioniert hier auf gib alles der typ lebt das def leben so muss das sein
hat er ja das sieht auch relativ plass aus da macht das schon mal richtig 100 prozent
homeoffice ja so muss das sein ja und jetzt noch mal was zu diesem thema kompilieren und
sozusagen wie gesagt das ist alles ein bisschen schwammig heutzutage kannste nicht mehr so
ganz klar sagen also zum beispiel javascript hatten wir schon in dotnet ist es teilweise
ähnlich dotnet übersetzt das erst mal in so einem zwischenschritt in so einem optimierten
zwischensprache die man dann ausführen kann wenn man das framework installiert hat bzw.
nicht das framework die runtime installiert hat und nachdem das dann gestartet ist übersetzt
das dann auch die sachen direkt native in in bytes in bytes für die cpu und analysiert
auch ok was ist hier der meist benutzte fad in der anwendung und optimiert das weiter das
ist alles wirklich große hohe kunst heutzutage aber eine sache was ich schon immer persönlich
blöde finde ist die wichtig tour wenn du wenn du sagst problem hatte ich auch mit paar azubis
schon die also leute geraten sind ja so nach dem motto der azubi sagt ja ich hab da was
programmiert und da kommt dann irgendwann wichtig tour und sagt welche sprache hast du denn
verwendet und dann sagt dann der azubi ja ich hab hab das mit einem python tutorial
gemacht oder sagt ja du hast nicht programmiert du hast gescriptet und das geht mir immer
so mega auf den sack diese leute das ist doch schwachsinnig gescriptet ist selbstverständlich
auch programmiert aber kennt ihr so leute kenne so leute das ist richtig richtig hängen
geblieben programmieren ist der überbegriff davon scripten ist auch programmieren aber
nicht jedes programmieren muss zwangsläufig scripten sein das ist richtig wird aber so
leute kennst du wahrscheinlich rust ja rust ist die giga chat sprache wir machen ja richtig
ist so deswegen verstehe ich die diskussion darum gar nicht selbstverständlich das ist
alles programmieren ja es gibt sprachen die sind zum scripten gedacht das ist dann hauptsächlich
halt dinger die sich gut eignen für quick und dirty sachen zum automatisieren aber es
ist nicht jedes also jedes scripten ist programmieren aber nicht jedes programmieren ist das ist
das ist das ist blöd wer also cringe also wenn ich mit dem hex editor programmiert
ist eh zu high level ja so gut zur diskussion hast du ja überall so was passiert hier aha
download läuft und hier läuft der download auch noch aber aus irgendwelchen gründen
geht gründen geht das hier schneller hier geht der download schneller als oh nee oh nee
zwei prozent fuck nee warum ist der download von bin utils cross arm so langsam 56k ich
brächte es wenn er fertig kompilieren ist mit allem was er kompilieren kann werde ich
abbrechen und noch mal neu starten in der hoffnung es geht dann schneller auch immer
es geht postchamp postchamp es geht hoch es geht hoch ja ist auch total unnötig irgendwas
wollte ich noch sagen ja wir machen übrigens demnächst was rast wir machen rast web assembly
ich habe nämlich ein richtig cooles tutorial gesehen für rast web assembly und wir werden
das nicht alles machen ja nur so ein bisschen uns label champ das war heute wir haben so
viele sachen die wir machen müssen dass also wir haben genug programm für die nächsten
jahre wenn es danach geht also wir bauen kein eigenes game of life nach oder so aber wir
gucken uns das mal ein bisschen an weil ich will eine sache probieren ich möchte probieren
ob ich es schaffe ffm pack im browser laufen lassen zu können ich weiß dass das geht ich
weiß auch dass es das schon fertig gibt aber ich würde gerne low level drauf zugreifen
ob man beispielsweise also was ich mir überlegt habe ob ich es irgendwie schaffe eine video
datei an den browser zu streamen ist ja noch kein problem in einem format was der browser
standardmäßig nicht kann und es dann kleinzeitig mit web assembly ffm pack on the fly zu decoden
und die rgb frames dann in irgendein canvas zu rendern das mit on the fly ist natürlich
so ein ding ich denke mal ffm pack in web assembly wird bei weitem nicht so performant sein wie
ffm pack native dementsprechend beschränken wir uns da mal auf ein normales etwas kleineres
älteres video in parlauflösung oder so was ist web assembly und was macht das ok da
muss ich jetzt da muss ich jetzt ein bisschen ein bisschen ausholen
hat nicht irgendjemand gürtelstraße vorhin haftbefehl haftbefehl gerappt im chat wo
ist es hin ich finde es nicht also was ist web assembly ich versuche das mal ganz genau
dass das also ich versuche das mal ganz kurz zu erklären also normalerweise ist es ja so
wir können also eigentlich auch ein bisschen ausführlicher erklären weil das kompilieren
noch ein bisschen dauert
ob ist es so langsam ok das lassen wir jetzt noch das lassen wir jetzt noch kompilieren
und danach brechen wir mal ab und starten also ganz kurz also normalerweise ist es ja so
in diesem video nur ganz kurz also normalerweise ist es ja so sachen im browser also zum beispiel
dieser twitch chat hier das ist css html javascript so seit ein paar jahren gibt es jetzt was
neues im browser und das nennt sich web assembly angefangen hat das ganze glaube ich alles
mit so einem proof of concept ich glaube das da aufbauen auf asm.js wird das binärformat
ich glaube damit hat das alles damit hat das alles angefangen das ist aber schon ein paar
jahre her wir gucken übrigens gerade mal was meint ihr wie die safaris was meint ihr wie
das safari support für web assembly ist oder safari support für ios web assembly web web
s o was wie was was funktioniert und das safari was ist denn da los ich falle ja vom glauben
ab was was in safari geht und das überall was ist denn safari tp technology preview
tatsächlich tut euch das man das meiste wird vom safari support der beidu browser kann
es nicht china chinesen browser so und es gibt seit ein paar jahren was neues und zwar
web assembly ich habe da keine große erfahrung drin muss ich gleich sagen also vielleicht
man ist nicht so ganz zu 100 prozentig was ich jetzt erzähle also seit ein paar jahren
gibt es einen neuen versuch noch eine weitere möglichkeit im browser zu etablieren wie
man dort programme ausführen kann neben javascript der ansatz ist aber ein bisschen anders javascript
ist ja hauptsächlich gedacht um webseiten interaktiv zu machen bei web assembly ist
das ein bisschen anders web assembly kannst du beispielsweise gar nicht benutzen um webseiten
interaktiv zu machen das musst du weiterhin über javascript aufrufe machen also wenn
jetzt zum beispiel hier draufklicks und das irgendwie auf blob dann ist das javascript
nach wie vor was web assembly ist web assembly ist wohl eine relativ minimalistische ein
mini relativ minimalistischer befehlssatz den jeder browser mittlerweile implementiert
hat dass man als compile target verwenden kann für andere programmier sprachen also
sprich mal angenommen du hast einen du hast ein programm in c oder c++ oder in rust oder
in go dann kannst du sagen hey go compiler mach mir aus meinem programm mal ein lauffähiges
programm für den raspberry pi oder mach mir mal ein lauffähiges programm für den x86
desktop rechner du kannst aber jetzt mittlerweile auch sagen wenn du eine programmier sprache
und ein compiler hast der das kann kannst aber auch sagen mach mir da raus mal ein lauffähiges
web assembly programm und dann kannst du quasi in jeder x beliebigen programmier sprache
was programmieren und kannst es als compile target web assembly nehmen und es damit im
browser ausführen natürlich gibt es limitationen also du kannst prinzipiell natürlich in der
programmier sprache mit den sachen die da eingebaut sind machen was du willst also kannst
schleifen machen ifs machen funktionen machen und so ist kein problem wo es dann halt natürlich
aufhört ist wenn du so sachen machen möchtest wie tcp sockets öffnen das geht in web assembly
nicht weil das wäre eine ziemliche sicherheitslücke wenn ein browser auf einmal tcp sockets aufmachen
kann oder lokale files vom filesystem lesen ja also du kannst in deinem go programm natürlich
sagen open file c doppel punkt windows desktop blub punkt txt du kannst das dann auch cross
kompilen zu web assembly das wird ja aber nichts bringen weil der browser nach wie
vor trotzdem nicht auf deine lokale falls zugreifen darf ist aber auch gut so weil das
wäre sicherheitslücke hoch 10 ok also das mit dem kompil hier geht nicht vorwärts weil
die bin utils nicht runtergeladen werden können ist schon mal geil soll ich breche ab und
start ist neu und vielleicht gehts dann schneller noch mal ich hoffe der fängt jetzt nicht
wieder von vorne an cache easy jep jep jep cache jep cache
es macht dann gar nichts mehr
moment moment jetzt ging der download jetzt einfach durch
ist ja jetzt einfach durchgelaufen der daule ok buchstacht sage ich nix dagegen kein problem
mit alles ok einfach nochmal neu gestartet und es funktioniert bitbake ist ein cooler
name fürs kompil ja das ist irgend so ein embedded kram jetzt ok die kiste brennt wieder
hetzer denkt wir meinen kryptowährung wir Leute wir brennen uns den weg frei demnächst
kommt mein server in australien irgendwo unten raus und die frage hoch und kommt die hetzer
kiste her und da gucken sie drauf sagen ah ah der max kompiliert grad tv herdend sieh
in awp danke für den zapp
wer dachte kernschmelze gibts nur im atomkraftwerk da muss ich einfach nur den cloud genug cpu
kerne mieten und dann drauf hauen was macht diese tv herdend damit kannst du fernseh
also kannst du fernsehprogramm empfangen mit wenn du tuner hast im rechner und kannst
das streamen an so viele endgeräte wie du willst im haus oder theoretisch auch nicht
nur im haus aber da kommen wir jetzt in langsam illegale gefilde deswegen sage ich da nichts
zu also kannst quasi wenn du den rechner hast mit einem tuner drin kannst du dort das tv
im programm empfangen und überall im haus hin streamen ja und warum ich das mache ist
ich habs ja hier schon installiert aber das ist eine alte version und ich will erstens
einen mini bug gefixt haben der mittlerweile gefixt ist und übrigens übelst flashbang
und ich will einfach gucken wie das funktioniert weil eine 2 jahre alte version ist doof das
nutzen die bei diesen illegalen diensten nein nein nein machen sie nicht da wird was anderes
benutzt wenn du irgendwelche streaming seiten meinst nee nee da verwenden die kein tv herdend
aber es gibt zum beispiel seiten die es streamen premiere und sky und sowas in der richtung
und da könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen dass das source material in irgendeiner art
und weise mit tv herdend ausgelesen wird weil es halt sehr praktisch ist weil man es direkt
in einem streambaren format hat
kann das repo das heißt ja nicht premiere ist das sky ist ja gut chat kann das repo nicht
github actions nutzen oder ist das too much mit dem compile das ist too much wenn du
das mit github actions machen willst auch immer wir konnten wir haben ok wir haben uns eine
bildumgebung gebildet um uns jetzt unseren bild compiler zu bilden damit wir weitere
pakete bilden können mit dem mit gcc ich würde sagen sobald gcc kompiliert ist sollte
es deutlich schneller gehen hier weil gcc ist halt einfach die voraussetzung für so
ziemlich alles ohne gcc geht halt nix
warum ist die musik aus das geht aber nicht anzeige direkt gucken wir gleich noch interessiert
mich was da rauskommt
habe ich erklärt habe ich erklärt so ja habe ich auch erklärt kann er dir ja kann
er du kannst dvbt dvbs dvbc machen der mustertuner im prinzip ist es weniger den job von tv
headend der tuner muss treiber technisch unter linux unterstützt werden und dann geht es
in der regel auch in tv headend
welchen clipboard manager rufy clipboard oder rufy clip
rufy clip heißt das glaube ich das da hier
billy greenclip genau greenclip und dann rufy clip irgendwie als frontend ja ja greenclip
ist das richtig ok gcc bildet etwas langsam der andere ist immer noch nicht fertig aber
ok jetzt gehts jetzt flutscht jetzt wieder gcc gcc ok wir brauchen natürlich noch glibc
aber glibc sollte schnell gehen
wobei ist es glibc glibc geht schnell im vergleich zu wie heißt die c++ standard library glib
c++ oder so dann glib standard plus plus nee ach was auch immer ist mir eigentlich ehrlich
gesagt komplett scheiß egal wie die c++ standard library heißt ich meine ok c++
er ist wirklich halbes gentoo erlebnis juckt mich nicht wie die standard wie die standard
library hier im package manager heißt wer c++ freiwillig macht hat in die kontrolle
über sein leben verloren manchmal kommst du nicht drum herum aber es gibt tatsächlich
leute die machen das freiwillig also quasi wenn ihr sagt ahja neues projekt was nehme
ich denn da gibt es leute die sagen tatsächlich und ungebated c++ ja normale leute sagen dann
vielleicht sowas wie dot net z sharp oder go oder meinetwegen rust oder wenns sein muss
elektron node js javascript oder was auch immer ja es ist egal c es ist meinetwegen
sogar d wobei ich noch nie was in d gemacht habe es ist egal was man da eigentlich instinktiv
sagt solange es nicht c++ ist aber es gibt wirklich ein paar verrückte leute die sagen
wenn ich ein neues projekt anlege das klar mach ich in c++ mach alles in c++ und ich
meine jetzt nicht wenn man nicht dran vorbeikommt ja wenn man irgendwelches microcontroller
zeug macht keine frage kommst du nicht dran vorbei gerade wenn es arduino kompatibel
ist oder ein esp 32 ist kommst du an c++ nicht wirklich vorbei gibt es da theoretisch andere
möglichkeiten aber da ist mit c++ geschlagen wenn du irgendeinen cute gui machst vielleicht
auch c++ meinetwegen ja wenn du irgendwie so unreal zeugs selbst machen willst wobei
kannst du unreal logik nicht mittlerweile sogar auch in c sharp machen habe ich dann
irgendwas gehört letztens richtig cute cute cute chat der cute chat ob es kann er schreiben
cute chat oder vielleicht auch der cute chat unreal zeugs geht das jetzt das finde ich
cool also unity kannst schon lange kannst schon lange machen also ja dann verstehe ich
wenn du nicht an c++ vorbeikommst aber es gibt leute die machen wirklich standardmäßig
ihre neuen projekte in c++ obwohl sie dieses projekt ohne problem in jeder anderen sprache
machen könnten was unity ist warum warum warum sollte unity hart dippen es gibt doch so viele
leute mit mit erfahrung in unity ach die aktie ja es ist schwierig in c++ zwei zeilen zu
fabrizieren die safe sind also wer es war safest programmieren will und es gleichermaßen
wahnsinnig schnell haben will nimmt rust wobei ich halt sagen muss rust ist mir ist mir zwar
von der sündungs und der konsistenz her und allem tausend mal lieber als c++ aber rust
ist schon ziemlich high iq also rust ist gerade wenn man mal ein bisschen komplexe rustprogramme
sich anguckt die gehen im prinzip gefühlt über einen halben bildschirm weil du so oft
unwrap und extract und und haste nicht gesehen machen musst und die ist ich finde rust hat
auch keine so griffige sündungs also rust besteht viel aus feilen aus spitzen klammern
und doppelpunkten und so ich mein klar die ganzen funktionalen leute werden sich da wie
zu hause fühlen aber ich finde rast relativ anstrengend zu lesen und zu schreiben aber
rast ist cool rast ist wirklich nice und das ist eigentlich das eines der coolen sachen
die man mazilla letzten jahre zu verdanken haben rast was ist das du meinst ein ruby
so bin gerade erst dazu gekommen gibt es einen grund warum ihr alles kompiliert nicht das
fertige binary aus dem package manager ja weil es kein fertiges binary aus dem package manager
gibt ich möchte nämlich für meinen linux receiver eine eine neue tv headend version
kompilieren aktuell gibt es tv headend aber das ist eine version von 2020 und die ist
relativ alt und ich will eine neue version haben und die gibt es nicht das heißt es bleibt
mir nichts anderes übrig als den kram selbst zu kompilieren für die architektur und die
zielplattform von meinem linux receiver willst du das kompilierte binary zur verfügung stellen
finde ich nicht ich meine ich könnte ich könnte damit irgendwelche daily gescripteten daily
builds aufsetzen oder so aber ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht ob das mir die arbeit wert
ist das ich meine ich könnte ich könnte das machen ich könnte das bereitstellen und sogar
anbieten dass man dann müsste ich den aber aber leute wisst ihr wobei eigentlich wäre
das ein richtig cooles streamprojekt dass wir dass wir weekly builds machen gescriptet
mit irgendeinem ansible wir machen uns wir machen uns ein ansible playbook das ist ja
die server oder terraform terraform wir müssen ja mit der zeit gehen leute terraform macht
man ja heute wir machen wir machen terraform wie heißt es bei terraform eigentlich das
heißt es nicht playbook config ja da machen wir unsere terraform config und bauen dann
die kisten automatisch damit auf wir haben schon genug laufende projekte ja gut wir haben
nahezu unendlich zeit ja ich werde ich werde mal keine ahnung 85 bis dahin müssen wir
irgendwie mit mit stream füllen weekly ansible terraform hetzer cloud ja also da könnten
wir einen weekly build machen da könnten wir einen weekly build aufsetzen was dann
ansible oder terraform oder was auch immer uns eine fette kiste erstellt darauf das build
environment hochzieht wobei ich das anders machen würde da würde ich mir auf irgendeiner
storage box da würde ich mir auf irgendeiner storage box das letzte build environment
zwischenspeichern weil ganz ehrlich jedes mal das hier zu machen da flippe ich aus das
halte ich das geht net und es ist dann auch viel viel viel schneller und dann könnte
man das tatsächlich einmal die perl giste weg geht monka es warum wird hier einfach
perl kompiliert perl giste weg in fünf sekunden ist es fertig angeblich
so weekly build für ascii aquarium was aber das könnte man echt ausprobieren das ist
das ist eine gute idee das finde ich es wäre ein nice nice streamprojekt nutzt du nutzt
du eine windows vm oder wie machst du das nee ich benutze keine windows vm ich habe
eine linux vm auf dem zweiten windows desktop und da kann ich dann zwischen dazwischen
also ich habe drei windows desktops kann man ja mittlerweile hier unten wer das nicht
weiß der knopf da macht das manche leute kennen das noch nicht dieser knopf kannst
verschiedene desktops machen unter windows und dann drückst du control windows taste
feiltaste rechts kannst die desktops durchswitchen und dann mache ich halt einfach ich switch
auf den zweiten desktop klick rein bin da vm so klick raus und bin wieder auf der windows
kiste control alt feiltasten genau man muss sich das angehört aus der vm aus der vm kommt
man mit control alt raus also im prinzip was ich mache ist control alt control windows
taste rüber control alt control windows hast du rüber überhaupt kein ding rust ist richtige
feiltage zeit six heller time schon ja wie gesagt es gibt anwendungszwecke da kommt
jetzt muss ich wirklich vorbei da sage ich nichts dagegen aber für alles andere ist einfach
ja wir können wir können das wir können das sogar scripten über github action aber
das macht keinen sinn weil wir haben kein source code warum soll ich mit github actions
scripten also das würde ich tatsächlich das würde ich tatsächlich lokal dann laufen
lassen bei mir also nicht den bild sondern das kript zum bilden du brauchst ja ein script
was den was deine cloud vms was deine cloud vms ich habe noch einen zweiten monitor was
deine cloud vms hochzieht und dann dort das repo auscheckt und alles das würde ich in
der cloud machen aber das eigentliche bild script das würde ich wahrscheinlich irgendwo
hier einmal die woche ausführen also nicht von hand irgendwo automatisch brauch ja nix
an leistung ein iot backend in c++ na gut wenn das selbst wenn das selbst auf irgendwelchen
embedded dinger laufen soll kann ich verstehen aber wenn es ein web endpoint ist und wie
ist fertig leute es ist fertig es hat fertig kompiliert pocham so wo ist jetzt wo ist jetzt
mein tv head end hin angeblich müsste ich jetzt einen tv head end haben find name tv
head end da ist es guck mal hier für cortex a15 hf das ist irgendein armbild ja und schon
im richtigen package format und ein aktuelles bild guck mal das ist git 10.844 plus den
und das hier ist git 1190 also wir sind schon ein bisschen weiter mit comments mittlerweile
würde ich sagen wir sind wir sind also schon so ungefähr 8000 comments weiter und das
da hinten ist der patch das ist irgendein zusatz patch der juckt mich nicht weiter
also ja wir haben es geschafft easy eigentlich oder das sehe ich das jetzt richtig wir haben
das angeschmissen und das ging einfach also das bin ich jetzt aber im linux umfeld nicht
gewöhnt dass es einfach geht ob es sich jetzt ausführen lässt weiß ich nicht ich will
es jetzt auch nicht auf nähe ich kann es nicht installieren weil er weil der receiver gerade
in benutzung ist aber ich ich werde es euch berichten das ist quasi das gegenstück wie
wenn man auf der arbeit sagt da ich da bin ich dran das kann ich eigentlich abbrechen
wenn wir gehen noch nicht ins bett wir gehen noch nicht ins bett wir gucken noch ein video
jetzt hat funktioniert sondern kann ich die cloud vm jetzt ja löschen im endeffekt weiß
ich mal sekunde nein ich kann die cloud vm nicht löschen ich muss mir erst tv header
drunter kopieren jetzt hätte leute das wäre es jetzt oder das wäre es jetzt echt gewesen
lull ssh so ok also wo sind wir hin scp
kein snap home wie haben wir das ding genannt übrigens ein weiterer vorteil den viele nicht
kennen wenn man anstatt passworte ssh keys verwendet kann man autocomplete machen auf
dem remote haus mit scp also home open art tv bilder temp also ihr seht dass es verzeichnet
struktur auf dem remote haus so bilds bisschen laggy aber es funktioniert open art tv release
nemoin wo ist es denn ja hier ist es da da ja tmp deploy das da also also ist eigentlich
bild tmp und ich bin grad release mein wo muss ich hin open art tv release ach ja tmp
release uno 4k tmp deploy ipk uno 4k se ja und da ist ein tv header jetzt oder im moment
tv header ist ja für die plattform hier hier tv herrent so viel zeug alter hausdruck an
tv herrent brauche ich nur tv herrent hier das da brauche ich ipk da ist es und sagt
er mir was das für eine datei ist debian binary package debian ok was auch immer soll
mir recht sein also habe ich abgezogen und jetzt kann ich die cloud vor allem löschen
weil die 60 euro im monat kostet ich habe am endeffekt habe ich jetzt ich habe jetzt
quasi 20 cent bezahlt dafür glaube das ist in ordnung bäm vor allem weg zack ausgelockt
so und jetzt gucken wir uns noch das video an ich bin immer gespannt
man kann sich aus das aus der vm raus gerne umbinden habt dasselbe haben wir mit zaha das
eine gute idee hast du eine empfehlung für einsteiger aktuell seit fünf jahren als
system mit einsteiger für was was meinst was meinst du du meinst programmiert technisch
ja ehrlich gesagt da gibt es eigentlich eine universal antwort also es sei denn ok nein
es gibt mehrere es gibt eine universal antwort und und dann je nachdem andere was du wenn
du vielleicht schon weiß was du machen willst die universal antwort ist javascript weil
man an javascript und frontend sachen heutzutage absolut nicht vorbeikommt egal ob man system
integrator ist full stack oder im defops bereich sei egal frontend ahnung ein bisschen muss
man eigentlich überall haben und ich glaube das beste universelle was man machen kann
ist tatsächlich javascript und dementsprechend halt sich auch noch ein bisschen die browser
sachen dazu angucken ich meine du kannst theoretisch javascript auch im backend verwenden gibt
ja leute die verwenden tatsächlich note js in ihrem backend habe ich gehört oder es
gibt leute die machen mit elektron desktop anwendungen und solche dinger also mit javascript
kannst du sehr vielfältig alles machen ich persönlich bin ich der größte javascript
fan ich mags aber mittlerweile eigentlich ganz gern ich meine alles besser als t++ pyson
ist auch eine wunderbare programmiersprache kommt ein bisschen auf die bereiche an wo
du dich interessierst ja meine meine persönliche lieblingssprache ist die sharp also dotnet
core dotnet heißt ja nur noch microsoft hat sie umbenannt hat mit dotnet framework nichts
zu tun muss man dazu sagen die microsoft benahmung ist einfach nur scheiße dir blickt keiner
durch bei microsoft ja die sharp auf dotnet basis ist so mein favorit für alles wo sich
nicht irgendwie was anderes anbietet go ist auch sehr beliebt kannst du eigentlich nichts
falsch machen also wenn du wenn du davon was nimmst kannst du eigentlich nicht nicht viel
falsch machen ich persönlich finde halt so universell immer ganz praktisch wenn man sagt
javascript weil du kommst an frontend sachen nicht vorbei und javascript ist halt auch
universell mittlerweile einsetzbar gar nix da ist nix angestöpselt dass der fernsehspar
hdmi an einem android tv angeschlossen so also welches video soll ich mir angucken
das da bam programmieren im home office das verdient ein software engineer alles klar
anita habe ich das video noch mal auf hä wir gucken uns das video da an das ist dann
schauen wir mal dann schauen wir mal was verdient ein software engineer also dieser software
engineer er hat schon mal er hat schon mal ein gutes setup ja er hat schon mal ein richtig
gutes setup er hat einen minimalen curved monitor dann noch einen alten neben dran und
davor ein laptop ich muss ja sagen mein lieblings setup wäre das so nicht ich mag nämlich
nicht wenn ein monitor vor dem anderen monitor steht auch nicht wenn es mein laptop ist ich
kenne genug leute die machen das bei uns auch so die haben den bildschirm und davor noch
den laptop ich habe den laptop wenn überhaupt daneben stehen hat jeder so sein ok ich habe
immer dahinter gedanken wenn ich jemals meinen job verliere oder irgendwas in der richtung
dass ich innerhalb von einer woche einen neuen bekommen der macht einen äußerst gechillten
eindruck hast du das auch schon gesehen twitch wupplos das da wer jagt die hacker moment
das ist auch was das muss wir das müssen wir uns finden fürs wochenende merken alina
wird cyberkop auch nie ist alina die die eine aus diesem anderen aus diesem video die die
so nervig war ne oder das war adriane das war adriane hieß die das ist jemand anderes
ne ne ne ne das ist ok nein dann habe ich nichts gesagt adriane war das die fand ich
irgendwie nervig das gucken wir uns am sonntag an also der macht einen äußerst äußerst
gechillten eindruck ja der typ erst mal erst mal dickes auto wichtig kann ich jeder mit
opel agila rumfahren wie ich das ist wahr das ist tatsächlich so man muss sagen gerade
leute mal ist ernsthaft gerade wir die sind in so einem technikumfeld arbeiten und bestimmt
natürlich nicht alle ja aber ganz im ernst ganz im ernst was er sagt ist schon was dran
also von uns nagt keiner wirklich am hungerbrot und die sache mit ich möchte mehr geld ist
eigentlich eher aus dem grund dass man sagt hey ich will nicht dass dass man arbeitgeber
so billig bekommt so wirklich brauchen tun es eigentlich die wenigsten also klar du hast
leute die haben sich ein haus gekauft haben irgendwie familie und und wollen die haben
große ambitionen aber die meisten und ich schließ mich damit ein also es ist nicht so
dass ich sagen würde also leute ich komme damit nicht über die runde oder so also uns
geht es schon wirklich gut in dieser richtung zumal wir auch allesamt in einem sehr zukunftssicheren
job arbeiten aber auf der anderen seite wenn es mehr geld gibt würde ich auch nicht nein
sagen heute hat übrigens gespräch über mehr gehalt mit meinem chef wo wir gerade bei diesem
thema sind mehr geld nehme ich natürlich auch immer und was mich halt immer ärgert
ist wenn man sich mal so umschaut und dann teilweise sieht ich guck mal da gibt es job
angebote die einfach mal 20 30k oder so mehr ok das jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben
aber zwar doch habe ich schon gesehen job angebote die durchaus mal 20 20 20 kam mehr
20 30k war eigentlich wirklich gar nicht übertrieben mehr bieten und wenn man das dann vergleicht
dann denkt man sich auch so jetzt wird es aber mal zeit dass hier mal ein bisschen
mehr rumkommt aber wirklich brauchen in form von leute ich weiß nicht wie ich mir am ende
des monats was zu essen kaufen soll ist es das ist wirklich jammern auf sehr hohem niveau
bei uns hi ich bin alex ich bin 23 jahre ich bin programmierer und arbeite 100 prozent
im homeoffice bester mann der hat der hat es raus ich stehe noch mal zwischen acht und
zehn auf je nachdem man nach dem schmeckt ich habe morgens immer erst mal den e-mails
das macht jeder e-mails e-mails gucken und zumindest wenn ihr das nicht macht sagt ihr
dass ihr es macht dass die leute euch morgens erst mal eine stunde in ruhe lassen aktuell
nichts normalerweise schrei ich mir an was ich den tag über mache und schreibt in kurz
unseren stand-up channel so ein ding so ein ding haben wir auch so ein teams chat man das
ist nicht teams das ist keine ahnung irgendwas anderes sowas sowas haben wir auch ein open
source konkurrenz im prinzip und der table kann sich so vorstellen wie aber online und
mit mehr featuren und mehr meine beiden tues für heute sind einmal den infobutton schreiben
und auf feedback ist das so ein großes ding in infobutton zu machen ja reagieren von der
community und von den an die member der infobutton selbst wird wahrscheinlich ein paar stunden
dauern den support ok vielleicht unterschätze ich das jetzt maßlos ein infobutton ich stelle
mir das so vor irgendwo hast du einen dialog wo nicht ganz klar ist was der macht oder
irgendwas was es nicht macht da kommt ein info icon daneben und dann geht ein pop-up
auf wo drinne steht oder ein overlay oder so wo drinne steht mit dieser funktion können
sie das und das machen programmieren aber vielleicht ist es doch deutlich komplexer
insgesamt ja gut man muss sagen ich bin jetzt in eine falle getappt die man gerne macht
das reine programmieren ist ja gar nicht das was die zeit frisst in dem fall wahrscheinlich
sondern der muss ja auch noch alle anderen sachen beachten die man da drum herum machen
muss ja vielleicht muss er noch mit irgendwelchen designers mieten wie diese infobutton am besten
gemacht werden soll dann muss er vielleicht noch irgendwelche design guides sich angucken
dass das alles passt dann muss er eventuell irgendwelche tests programmieren ob der infobutton
richtig ist dann muss er das eintüten dass das ins nächste deployment reinkommt da muss
es vielleicht noch in einer staging umgebung getestet werden da hängt schon ein bisschen
was dran je nachdem wie sehr die das übertreiben oder nicht vielleicht vielleicht gibt es
auch irgendwelche tests mit anwälten also mit mit mit wirklich mit anwender mit irgendwelchen
leuten die dafür bezahlt werden so zu tun als wären sie anwender kann ja alles sein
weiß man ja im prinzip die mockup erstellt das bedeutet er ok ich wusste er wusste sein
dokument angucken tool ungefähr da ist wo ist der infobutton
ja kein infobutton wo ist er leute wo ist der infobutton aufgebaut wie es aussehen soll
alles was man hier sieht gibt es bereits das einzige was neu ist ist hier unten das blau
da ist der infobutton ich sehe ihn den infobutton guckt euch an da ist er das tageswerk dieser
blau button also dieser blau link und das heißt so soll es ungefähr aussehen das heißt
leute wenn ich mir diese anwendung so angucke ist das eine web anwendung oder ist es was
native mäßiges ich kann es auf den ersten blick nicht erkennen was was für die spricht
sollte es eine web anwendung sein das ist der blau links unten sein aber wenn man drauf
drückt öffnet sich so ein pop base row ist nice ich hab von base row nie was gehört
pop und da sind dann die informationen drin spezifisch hier bei der aufgabe ist es nur
wichtig dass alles gut aussieht und dass der text gut formuliert ist das ist eigentlich
das wichtigste ok ich mein das sind vier wörter also ok ich schreibe immer den englischen
text zuerst und manchmal muss ich das nicht auf deutsch übersetzen weil ich nicht weiß
wie man es vernünftig auf deutsch formulieren soll das kenne ich damit kann ich mich wirklich
gut identifizieren das gleiche problem habe ich auch öfters ihr hört manchmal meine
wirren setze hier im stream ja ich weiß ich weiß manchmal die wörter gar nicht auf deutsch
mehr und gut übersetzen macht das besser als ich also kopiere ich einfach schnell und dann
schaue ich mir so ja ja das ist schon besser als was ich wahrscheinlich geschrieben hätte
wird dynamisch vor ausfüllen sehr deutsch fantastisch der ist cooler typ den mag ich
habe dabei im zweiten jahr angefangen mit meinem eigenen start-up als co-founder habe
das zwei jahre lang gemacht bin dann zwei jahre lang zur amerikanischen firma gegangen
und jetzt vor kurzem zu base roll gewechselt als immer als software engineer so soll am
ende aussehen der hier unten und so sieht aktuell aus was ist denn base roll
open source habe ich noch nie gehört
das quasi excel ihr wisst ich verwende kein office dementsprechend auch kein excel ich
komme in der regel mit text editor und markdown ganz gut aus
das ist so ein ding das ist so eine so eine low code no code hast du nicht gesehen geschichte
wo man sich so seine eigenen spreadsheet sachen zusammenstellen kann ja wo man dann sagen kann
ok was weiß ich hier gibt so und so viele inputfelder das und das soll dann berechnet
da kann an dem zweifelsfall die personal abteilung sich auch irgendwelche excel style sachen mit
zusammenstellen so was ist das wahrscheinlich in der richtung aber also sieht auf jeden fall
nice aus wüsste nicht wofür ich benutzen würde aber das steckt viel arbeit drin noch der ist
nicht so zentriert wie er sein soll und so weiter also also ich bin ich bin nicht der große css
meister das wisst ihr aus den streams ja aber den button zentriert zentriert das würde ich
wahrscheinlich auch in so einer halben stunde hinbekommen wir nähern uns aber wir sind nicht
ganz da von den button selbst 20 min ja siehst du sieht so aus wie er aussehen soll also der
passt jetzt nicht der schritt ist ist jetzt richtig zu zentrieren und jetzt noch nicht zentriert
also jetzt ist so zentriert vor was ich irgendwie komisch unten links und jetzt haben wir schon
mal dass es von der position her richtig ist also jetzt jetzt übertreibt das ja ein bisschen
oder jetzt verkauft er also jetzt hat er den jetzt hat er den film team jetzt wirklich was
simples als hohe fife hat er kunst verkauft oder leint in den ganzen anderen feldern man
schaut mir eine linie runterziehen würde dann wäre das wieder keine maus ok das könne ich
gerade web also gerade webentwicklung ohne maus stelle ich mir sehr anstrengend vor ich mache
aber wir haben auch bei uns leute auf der arbeit die stehen komplett auf touchpad ich mag es nicht
ich mag auch so touchpads nicht selbst wenn ich keine also ich mache mir ist dieser nippel bei
ibm notebooks lieber als touchpads aber also webentwicklung ohne maus könne ich mir nicht
vorstellen aber es hätte jeder so seine vorlieben mein kleines video funktioniert ja und schickt
das brahm um zu zeigen wie das funktioniert also mit der scroll war das um einfach nur kurz zu
fragen ob das so ist wie er gemeint hatte ja also was ich gemacht habe war in ordnung es sieht gut
aus also jetzt wo die wo die hälfte feature sind die fertig ist also der der button existiert der
ist richtig formuliert alles alles gut als nächstes kommt dann dass wir den infotext brauchen dass
man auf den button drauf drückt soll sich ein pop-up öffnen dachte ich mir dass so was kommt was der
zweite schritt ist aber zwischen dem ersten und zweiten schritt geben wir es noch mal raus mit
nala kurz laufen sind wir sehr aufgeregt wenn wir laufen gehen ich habe viel zeit über den tag ich
überlege gerade was schicko kostet wie viel gebe ich für schicko im monat aus 600 euro sind das nicht
aber schicko frisst natürlich auch nicht so viel wie nala jala oder so in der richtung
ach 60 ich habe das so aus dem augenwinkel angeguckt ich habe das euro zeichn gerade für
eine null gehalten 60 60 ja ok ja das schicko frisst in letzter zeit ziemlich viel das kommt
wahrscheinlich auch über den tag ich meine da muss irgendwann laufen also habe ich nicht
wirklich eine wahl ich kann auch sagen 60 euro mega krass jetzt fange ich auf jeden fall schon
mit dem model an und also diese pop-up model bedeutet pop-up also wenn man drauf drückt sollte
jetzt pop-up kommen dass sie gar nicht drückt haben model bedeutet eigentlich nicht zwangsläufig
dass pop-up ist sondern dass es das einzige element ist und die anderen dann nicht mal
anklicken kannst und so was kann es auch ein pop-up ohne model machen aber ich will nicht
pippen sicher sein als der papst ich meine so was muss man wirklich nicht in diesen beitrag
packen was passieren sollte ist du drückst drauf und dann kommt jetzt ein pop-up genau das muss
jetzt programmieren also das das funktioniert also schon drauf alles beschrieben so wie es
sein soll man klickt hier unten drauf dann kommt das hier ja und da ist jetzt einfach erklärt aber
das pop-up das pop-up ist bestimmt ein fertiges in ihrem framework was sie verwenden was sie
show pop-up und dann gibst dem text mit und ob nicht dass das dass das jetzt komplett auch
hier designed wurde weil im ernst wenn es das ist dann tatsächlich schon ein bisschen aufwändiger
das zu machen es wenn ich sie wirklich aufwändigen sie dass es großartig kompliziert ist aber du
musst dann gucken ok wie schreibst du diese hilfe und wie formatierst du dass das die leute das
direkt checken und das ist das ist deutlich anstrengender als einen komischen button wie
ein feature funktioniert was man benutzen kann ja ich bin zufrieden natürlich also ist nicht
perfekt will nicht für sehr komische bildschirme 100 prozent super aussehen aber vergängliche
bildschirme funktioniert dann sind wir eigentlich fertig könnte ja mal er könnte mal zeigen wie
wie geil responsive die webseite ist oder ein bisschen bisschen hin und zurück mal gucken wie
sich das pop-up ob sich das ob sich das ich glaube es kurs ist wahrscheinlich dass ich
weil wir könnten uns jetzt einen account machen wir könnten uns jetzt einen account machen bei
base row und diesen und und diesen hilfe button raussuchen ja und dann falls sie schon die blöde
haben und dann gucken ob das alles passt also wir eigentlich fertig aber ich finde den typ
cool er tut wenigstens nicht so als ist das jetzt hier wirklich 100 prozent permanent anspannung
auslastung sonst was aber das ist wichtig ja man darf das nicht unterschätzen programmiert ist
eine kreative aufgabe und gerade so was im web umfeld besonders und das kannst du einfach nicht
am fließband machen nur mit seinem computer aus nichts etwas erschaffen kann so wie wie man
buch schreiben und man fängt damit nichts an fängt was runterzuschreiben wenn du hast du ein buch was
was was wert bringt dasselbe ist mit programmieren schreibt eigentlich auch nur sachen und am ende
ist es was was wertvolles was nützliches also ganz ehrlich du schreibst die sachen runter nachdem
du diese in deinem kopf erst mal überlegt hast das ist ja die eigentliche herausforderung und
leistung dass abtippen nicht das überlegen und gedanken machen und das tippen ist ja dann quasi
plus das in texte das deswegen ist ja auch so hand aufs herz also die meisten programmierer
programmieren in der zeit wo sie programmieren vielleicht zu 40 prozent 30 40 prozent also
das programmieren was man sich vorstellt man tippt in die tastatur 60 70 prozent sind nachgucken
nachdenken überlegen lesen was an anderer stelle programmiert wurde ja ich gehe jetzt mittagessen
holen 12 uhr pünktlich wie sich das gehört in deutschland da muss das sein ich schaue mittags
das ist cool das ist cool das hat er den noch nur erzählt weil die das hören wollen oder
aber das cooler move für videospiele machen der kam so rüber als ob er das sehr gerne macht
das ist china chinesen zeug vor der da pock das ist das ist das ist hähnchen mit paprika
und das sieht fast so aus wie das was ich mir auch öfters bestelle
das ist china china china mann china chinesen zeug
die wohnung meiner mutter ich zahle meine umlagen aber keine keine blanco mieter ich
meine ich wohne auch im haus was wir von opa geerbt haben wenn es danach gibt es ja auch
wahrscheinlich mindestens eine person heute da drüber schaut und mir feedback gibt und
ich dann das feedback inventiere ich bin echt froh leute ich bin echt froh dass der opa damals
dieses haus gebaut hat ohne scheiß wenn ich mir teilweise angucke wie unmöglich das für
manche leute ist heutzutage ein haus zu haben irgendwann bin ich wirklich froh dass der opa
das gemacht hat und bei der opa hat es ja gar nicht gebaut der opa hat das gebaut also es hat
der es hat der opa gebaut der nach südafrika abgehauen ist und seine frau verlassen hat der
das haus gebraucht hat deswegen ich habe kein feedback bekommen also müssen wir uns was
irgendwas anderes suchen wir den rest des tages was wir machen können und da haben wir viele
issues also viele viele tickets die offen sind dann können wir uns eins raussuchen und schauen was
was spaß macht ich gehe jetzt durch unser unser board durch wie eine liste von massive
kanban board 5 header time jetzt wird jetzt wird es super agil guckt euch das an jetzt
können wir agilität live erleben da suche ich mir jetzt was raus was noch keinen anderen
zugewiesen wurde bruto verdiene ich ungefähr 6000 ein bisschen und nette sind das 3600 2
ist ja auch ist ja auch ist ja auch vollzeit ist ja auch vollzeit und die frage ist ganz ehrlich
wie viele wie viele wie viele monatslöhne im jahr ja ich hab grad so ich hab grad so
aber ganz ehrlich wenn man wenn das dann wirklich nur 12 monatslöhne sind dann ist das gut kannst
du nix sagen ganze gerade als einsteiger was er gesagt hat im endeffekt ist das wirklich ist
das wirklich nicht nicht nicht ohne aber es ist mal 12 was ist in das 68 78.000 oder so
irgendwie 72.000 der ist senior ja gut für senior dürfte es tatsächlich schon ein bisschen mehr
sein finde ich also für senior wie hat es denn wie hat es denn in zwei da muss richtig mega
feif herr sein alter der hat auch erst vor zwei jahren oder so als einsteiger angefangen hat
stand auch am anfang irgendwas da also 72.000 als senior ist ich würde jetzt nicht sagen schlecht
aber ich würde jetzt auch nicht sagen wirklich richtig gut wie wird ein senior definiert ja das
müssen wir mal seinen chef fragen was die da drunter weiß ich nicht in dem fall nette sind
das 3.602 ich meine wir verdienen nicht ganz so viel aber ähnlich wie zum beispiel wie ein
arzt und ich mein arzt muss zehn jahre ewigkeiten da nicht ohne recht ja der verdient ungefähr
also ähnlich wir verdienen wir verdienen fast das gleiche fast nicht ganz aber ungefähr das
gleiche nur bei mir ist es natürlich insgesamt unterm strich weniger weil ich teilzeit arbeite
nicht mal ein studium das einzige was ich können muss programmieren und das kann man sich selbst
in ein zwei jahren beibringen dass sie können gute edge case ein tatsächlich ganz ehrlich mir
würde auch eher edge case einfallen als ausnahmefall ich muss auch gerade überlegen wie würde ich
das denn jetzt übersetzen wobei ausnahmefall ja rand rand rand bedingungen oder sowas vielleicht
ran also als problem hier was wie polen wurde war das dass wir nur ein number separator er hatte
doch erst seine eigene firma ich habe auch meine eigene firma interessiert aber auch kein also
zum beispiel in der nummer schreibt sagt 12,5 oder sowas weil in deutschland benutzen wir
kommen amerikanisch oder englisch wenn wir punkt benutzen und aber aktuell das ist pence
das kann ich nachfühlen wie oft ich da schon probleme hatte mit punkt oder kommen ja wo sind
wir denn jetzt ist mal auf was ist mein browser eingestellt englisch ist die vollsprache oder
deutsch nutzen aber aktuell erlauben wir glaube ich nur amerikanische schreibweise ja ging gerade
darum ob wir vielleicht einfach eine bias akzeptieren könnten die normalität ist jetzt ist möglich zu
machen für leute die zum beispiel deutsch benutzen dass sie kommers benutzen können anstelle punkte
um um zahlen zu sein browser bevor wir das alles machen da musste da musste gucken auf was ist
der browser language ist der browser und dann musste hoffen dass das alles so stimmt und das
irgendwie konnte das stelle ich mir eklig vor so und so support bekommen aus einzubauen man von der
theorie ist einfach aber da hängt so viel dran zumal die auch irgendwie dann sicher gehen muss
die leute dürfen sich nicht vertippen also sonst ist es ein tausende trend zeichen und beim anderen
ist es ein kommer tausende trend zeichen was das kommer das ist schon ein ganz schöner unterschied
los in den hundepark und danach geht es weiter ja das muss so auf jeden fall kleinzeitig irgendwie
machen also auf dem server musst du definitiv in also anders kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
musst du das in einem konsistenten format speichern und dann jeweils anders rendern
bei den bei den leuten oder aber du machst eine sprache pro dokument das könnte könnte
man vielleicht auch machen dass man sagt man stellt das dokument dass man language für für
ein für eine table oder so einstellen kann dass es dann aber bei allen gleich ist keine
andere letztendlich glücklicherweise ist es auch nicht unser bier das muss er ja machen
so jetzt erstmal ich muss ich weiß nicht ob das tostmusik ist
ja der gönnt sich mir ist eher wichtig dass ich nach was spaß macht ich das war indirekter
des von meinem opel agila das auto gut das ist natürlich was er hat galeres kaliber sehe ich
ein ja die freut sich der agila der agila macht mir keinen spaß aber ich fahre selten
also ich fahre zu wenig auto als ich dass ich irgendwie bock hätte mir was neues zu
holen ich werde ihn fahren bis der nicht mehr fährt und die anzeichen sind ja schon da letztens
die reifen im arsch jetzt eine der felgen abgeplatzt letztens kann ich nicht mehr drauf
stecken manchmal manchmal zeigt er die tank füllung nicht mehr richtig an also
der ist wahrscheinlich nicht mehr allzu lange am start mein auto ja
ich meine ich bin gerne hier ich bin schön wenn wenn nadi hier rumrennt
wir sind zurück und auf geht's mit der nächsten task was ich jetzt konkret vor hab
zu programm ist einfach dass ich beides zulasse ich sage ok der user kann punkten
nehmen ich werde einfach beides akzeptieren das stelle ich mir gar nicht so easy vor das
mal kurz nebenbei zu machen also eine sache die wir auch machen ist dass wir sagen ok weil
diese eingabe selbst also das ist jetzt 12,1 wo eingeben könnte wenn ich möchte und wenn
ich den enter drücke dann macht er halt einfach ein punkt raus ja ganz kleinzeitig filter wenn
es dann darum geht was was der output ist dann machen wir es immer mit punkt also ich schaue
gleich ob man im endeffekt im endeffekt musste ich halt darauf verlassen dass das der jeweilige
user seine browser language so gesetzt hat oder aber du hast in dem benutzer profil was wo du
einstellen kannst was es ist die sache ist halt die man weiß dann halt nicht was gemeint ist
weil der könnte 12,1 geben und wirklich kommen meinen dann könntest du gucken ok nach dem
comma kommt nix mehr aber das also das wirklich sauber zu händeln stelle ich mir gar nicht so
easy vor zumal da ja mehrere leute auch an einem dokument arbeiten können generell sind
währungsformate zahlungsformate temperaturen und sowas ist wirklich ein riesen zeitzone leute
zeitzonen ist der größte abfakt der menschheitsgeschichte was man sich da ausgedacht hat
doppeldeutige bezeichnung und gerade wenn es in historische daten geht überschneidung und
und manchmal sonderfälle so irgendwie 30 februar in schweden 1200 noch was und so richtig eklig
also die idee war ja das haben wir eigentlich schon mal ein bisschen sausschraut richtig sehen
können von den kommen außer außer eben kurz mich jetzt weil er hatte doch eben kurz hier
irgendwas oder zeig mal eine sache die wir auch machen kann dass wir sagen ok weil diese
eingabe selbst also das ist jetzt 12,1 hatte man nicht eben was gesehen und wenn ich dann
hinterdrücke dann macht er halt einfach ein punkt raus bei man sieht nichts aber wenn es
dann darum geht was was der output ist dann machen wir es immer mit punkt also ich schau
gleich ob das alles funktioniert wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe also die idee war ja das
wahrscheinlich typescript oder so bestimmt javascript camp hier da jetzt beides reinschreiben
können also 12,5 eben konnten wir es gerade sehen oder 12.5 und beides einfach funktionieren dann
zu 12.500 jetzt unterdrücken dann funktioniert das und ja immer was gesehen 926 hat man nicht
gesehen ist aufworscht und beides auch einfach funktionieren dann zu 12.500 beste wenigstens
die wissen wie es was verfolgt zum glück von uns die mal ordentliche frontend frameworks beste
funktioniert das und immer noch mit punkt funktioniert also 12.5 geht auch noch und das
ist die simpelste lösung weil damit kann ich sichergehen dass der rest des systems auf jeden
fall noch funktioniert aber trotzdem beide beide sachen funktionieren mein abend sieht so dass ich
vielleicht arbeiten werde ein bisschen noch und ein bisschen spiele vielleicht meine freundin
rede vielleicht meine freundin rufe ich habe viel für die spiel gespielt als ich als jung war da
kam natürlich immer die der gedanke auf wie die ganzen sachen hinter hinten dran funktionieren
und daher kam ein interess auf am loll weiß ich weiß ich ob das tos musik ist keine ahnung
da kann es was mit anfangen etf besser etf stonks so muss das machen
auf jeden fall die bezahlung super gut dafür dass es einen spaßiger job ist mit dem man so
viel freiheit hat also ich habe auch etf stonks ja das war es von mir ich habe mich bei lohnt
sich dasselbe wollen wenn ihr auch lust hättet darauf dann werbt euch auch unter lohnt sich das
br.de abonniert den kanal und hier oben geht es zu meinem lieblingsvideo von den komponisten und
hier oben geht es zum nächsten video ich meine das sind 12.000 euro im jahr in etf das ist schon
ordentlich was er da am start hat und wenn das jetzt die man dieses jahr dieses jahr eher nicht
aber oder vielleicht noch keine ahnung aber über lange frist wird lange lange sich wird sich das
lohnen der definitiv wahrscheinlich ausgeben die 900 monat in die 900 euro auf dem konto für
dinger ja vielleicht für autotuning keine ahnung time zones ja das ist ein arsch also leute ich muss
jetzt oft muss jetzt ins bett schon spät stimmt er hat ja eine freundin da weiß er wo die kohle
schon hingeht er weiß wie kost wie kostspiel ich das ist was man alles machen muss so nach dem motto
schatz zu verdienen so so gut wollen wir nicht mal da und dahin wer weiß keine ahnung können wir
nur jetzt können wir nur raten was ist aus dem speed champ geworden da haben wir nie weitergemacht
bist du täglich live nee meistens nicht guck guck am besten mal in die stream history das ist
unregelmäßig also in letzter zeit bin ich relativ oft und aber täglich nicht so alle
zwei drei tage vielleicht in letzter zeit wenn es mir danach ist alles klar leute wir sehen
uns macht's gut bis zum nächsten stream zu